thanks to deep sentinel for keeping
legal eagles safe and sound get 15
off the only security system that stops
crime before it happens with a link
below
i know i speak for the vast majority of
americans when i say
thoughts and prayers to the nra thoughts
and prayers
these are troubled times for the
national rifle association the
nation's oldest gun rights organization
last year the nra chief executive wayne
lapierre who has been at the helm of the
organization for 30 years
was accused of financial fraud by former
nra president oliver
north when north accused lapierre of
spending donor money on private jet
travel and luxury wardrobe
lapierre fired him and the nra sued
north north countersued
claiming that he was a whistleblower who
was booted from the organization because
he repeatedly tried to warn others that
la pierre and other key employees
breached their fiduciary duties to the
nra
you know it's 2020 when oliver friggin
north is the one who's blowing the
whistle on
untoward and unscrupulous activity now
new york has accused la pierre and his
cronies of funneling millions of dollars
into their own pockets for lavish
vacations golf club memberships
luxury black car services african
hunting trips and much more
new york attorney general tis james
filed a lawsuit to dissolve the nra
following
an 18-month investigation that allegedly
found evidence of financial misconduct
that contributed to a loss of more than
64 million dollars over a three-year
period the suit alleges that top nra
executives misused charitable funds for
personal gain awarded contracts to
friends and family members
and provided contracts to former
employees to ensure loyalty
when nra board members tried to blow the
whistle on this allegedly fraudulent
conduct
they allegedly faced intimidation and
retaliation so it seems the new york ag
is out for blood and is looking to
dissolve the nra itself
can she do that is this just a partisan
political attack on a very successful
gun rights lobbying group or is there
more to the story
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because new york has the nra in
its crosshairs
see what i did there now according to
the state of new york the effect of the
nra's internal misconduct quote
has been to divert millions of dollars
away from the nra's charitable mission
imposing substantial reductions in its
expenditures for core program services
including gun safety education
training member services and public
affairs but the nra and its supporters
have slammed the lawsuit as just the
latest attempt by a blue state to cancel
a successful conservative group
isn't this just a lawsuit to crush an
influential conservative organization in
an election year rudy
of course it is i mean she's a poor
excuse for a lawyer anyway
and if a judge dissolves the nra in new
york what happens to the organization
nationally
well that's what we're going to find out
today now obviously when you talk about
the nra it
tends to get political and this raises a
couple of concerns
first as pope hat said it's perfectly
possible for two things to be true at
the same
time the nra is thoroughly corrupt and
the nyag's action is motivated by
political animus
and i think that that is a valid concern
we'll talk about that here that
there may be improper conduct going on
but it also may be that the
investigation is slightly motivated by
political animus
and that's probably not a good thing if
we support the first amendment we should
support it in
all cases even if people espouse beliefs
about things that we don't agree with
and obviously a lot of progressives
don't agree with the nra's position
but by that same token there's another
horn to this dilemma
which as my friend andrew at opening
arguments says the allegations against
the nra if true
not their political activities support
dissolution and to give them a break
because of their political activities
seems profoundly wrong
and i think that these are two things
that we should always keep in mind here
free speech is free speech we should
allow people to espouse their beliefs
and we
shouldn't punish people based on those
beliefs but at the same time
just because an organization is
political is also not a reason to give
them
a break this is a complicated subject
that probably deserves its own video and
we're going to try and thread the needle
here but
i think it's worth asking that if you
are on the political left
and a charity that you happen to
ascribe to like the aclu or planned
parenthood were accused and convicted of
the very same things that we're talking
about here would you support the
dissolution
of that charity in that circumstance but
with that in mind let's talk about the
applicable laws here
now there are at least 1.5 million
non-profit organizations in the united
states and
section 501 of the u.s tax code outlines
which types of non-profit organizations
may be granted a tax-exempt status by
the irs
this section states that organizations
are exempt from federal income taxes if
they fall under the section which you
might have heard before
501c the most common type of nonprofit
designation
is 501c3 which applies to groups which
are
organized and operated exclusively for
religious charitable scientific
testing for public safety literary or
educational purposes or to foster
rational
or international amateur sports
competition or for the prevention of
cruelty to children or animals
nonprofits organized under 501c3 cannot
be involved in lobbying or politics but
organizations that file
under 501c4 are permitted to engage in
some political activities without losing
their tax-exempt status
and the nra is organized as a section
501c4 organization
and like a section 501 c3 a c4
organization is tax-exempt for federal
income tax purposes
but that doesn't mean that they're
exempt from payroll taxes real estate
taxes and so on and in addition
donations to a c4 organization are
typically
not deductible by the donor as a
charitable contribution for
federal tax purposes but that's just
under the federal system states also
have
certain regulations and reporting
requirements for 501c4s
so let's talk about new york state law
and the attorney general's authority to
dissolve
a nonprofit the nra as a 501c4
corporation
is a charity under new york state law
subject to the authority of the new york
attorney general
and new york's not-for-profit law gives
the attorney general broad powers over
non-profits including
dissolving a corporation that has acted
beyond its capacity
restraining any person or persons from
acting as a domestic or foreign
corporation within the state
seeking a judgment removing a director
of a corporation for cause
restraining a corporation from
undertaking any activities in new york
state
and compelling the directors and
officers of a corporation which has been
dissolved to quote
account for the assets of a dissolved
corporation this gives the state aeg the
right to sue non-profits who don't
comply with new york law
barring them from operating the state
and dissolving their legal charter
and requiring the directors and officers
to pay back any money or assets that
were improperly diverted
so how often does this happen do the
courts ever dissolve a non-profit after
the state ag files a lawsuit
well yes courts have dissolved
non-profits when they commit serious
fraud
and despite the fact that it's sort of
been memory hold at this point
you might actually recall that the
donald j trump foundation is a prime
example of what happens
when a new york nonprofit violates the
law so let's talk about the state of
new york versus the trump foundation the
state of new york
sued the donald j trump foundation and
its directors president trump
donald trump jr ivanka trump and eric
trump for improper transactions going
back at least
10 years the lawsuit against the donald
j trump foundation was filed in june of
2018. the state said that trump
repeatedly used the foundation money for
his own personal business and political
interests
a judge concluded that trump and his
children flagrantly breached their
fiduciary duties
for example in 2016 the presidential
campaign
directly distributed 500 000 in
foundation money at a campaign rally
right before the iowa caucus then
candidate trump subsequently took credit
for making those payments citing them as
proof of his good deeds
in reality the money that he doled out
was not his own it was given by
individual donors to the trump
foundation by law
this money could not be distributed by
the campaign after the court's decision
president trump admitted to dozens of
violations of new york law including
using the foundation's funds for that
iowa campaign event
he also admitted that he used the
foundation funds to settle legal
obligations of
companies that he controlled and that
the foundation spent money on sports
memorabilia
and champagne as well as on a portrait
of trump that cost ten thousand dollars
trump admitted the foundation failed to
meet failed to provide oversight over
the foundation and failed to adopt
legally required policies and procedures
he admitted that these failures
contributed to the foundation's
participation
in seven illegal transactions the trump
family stipulated that the ag
could take possession of the charity's
remaining assets and that the foundation
would be legally dissolved if president
trump ever founds another new york
charity he will be subject to close
monitoring by the state
so please consider this your friendly
reminder that the president of the
united states was the head of a
fraudulent charitable organization that
diverted charitable funds away from
charitable ends like
helping cancer patients and used them
for his own
personal gain yeah that is
a thing that actually happened all right
we're going to talk about the
allegations against the nra
in a second and believe me they are
pretty scandalous
but first let's talk about some of the
requirements that new york has for
non-profits new york nonprofits must
appoint directors and officers who will
discharge the duties of their respective
positions in good faith
and with a care an ordinarily prudent
person in a like position would exercise
under similar circumstances
these individuals may only be paid quote
a reasonable amount for services
actually rendered
they cannot be paid from dividends or
from distributing quote any part of the
organization's income or
profit the board of directors must also
adopt implement and assure compliance
with the conflict of interest policy and
must implement a policy protecting
whistleblowers from retaliation
some non-profits must register and file
accurate and complete reports with the
attorney general executives cannot lie
or make misstatements in fact in any
financial statement that is filed with
the state
and the new york prudent management of
institutional funds act governs the
management and investment of funds held
by
not-for-profit corporations and other
institutions the nra does in fact hold
such institutional funds and the board
of directors has a duty
to use such funds for the good of the
company and not for themselves
so let's talk about the allegations of
the actual lawsuit itself
despite being a national organization
the nra was chartered by a special act
of the state of the new york legislature
on november 17
1871 and throughout its history it's
been legally domiciled in the state of
new york despite having its headquarters
in fairfax virginia
the nra has members and engages in
fundraising throughout the united states
and has
five key missions one to protect and
defend the second amendment
to promote public safety and law and
order to train people on
safe handling of small arms to promote
shooting sports and to promote and
defend hunting and interestingly the nra
of today looks
really nothing like the nra of 50 years
ago
frank smith the author of the nra the
unauthorized history
explains that the current makeup of the
nra relates back to the 1977
cincinnati revolt at which time hardcore
gun rights advocates
essentially launched a coup against the
current management of the nra
and took over the ideological structure
of the organization
and at the same time that the members of
the nra who launched the cincinnati
revolt and
made the organization tack to a much
more ideologically extreme positions
with
much more lobbying activity they also at
the same time
prevented any kind of public financial
disclosures from
being released which had been standard
practice up until that time
so with that in mind the new york ag's
lawsuit alleges that wayne lapierre and
the executive staff have effectively
looted the nra's funds
diverting the organization from
furthering the goals listed by their
mission statement
for personal gain unrelated to their
core missions information from several
whistleblowers is included in the
complaint including
two members of the nra board described
as dissident one and dissident two
described numerous efforts by la pierre
to block them from fulfilling their
legal obligations to fiduciaries
the new york lawsuit names the nra as a
corporate defendant and
also the top four officials at the nra
including wayne lapierre former chief
financial officer
woody phillips former chief of staff
joshua powell and general counsel john
fraser as individual defendants
the suit accuses la pierre of using
charitable funds for personal gain
including a post-employment contract
valued at more than 17 million dollars
that was not approved by the nra's board
of directors
lapierre allegedly received more than
1.2 million dollars in expense
reimbursements over four years including
gifts for friends travel expenses and
memberships at golf clubs and hotels
lapierre allegedly used money for
purposes unrelated to the nra's mission
such as
sending extended family on private
vacations paid for by the nra
even when he was not present traveling
to africa with his wife on a safari
gifted by an nra vendor
spending at least 3.6 million dollars on
luxury black car services and travel
consultants in just two years
and in the past five years lapierre and
his family have allegedly visited the
bahamas by
private air charter at least eight times
at a cost of more than five hundred
thousand dollars to the nra
although nra employees are required to
use the nra's in-house travel agent to
book travel
la pierre's travel was handled by an
outside travel agent who from 2016 to
2019
was paid a fixed fee of 19 000
a month and this kind of expense
obviously adds up fast
now the complaint alleges that lapierre
used a secret poison pill contract
to make him the chief executive officer
for life and a contract allegedly
requires lapierre to receive an annual
payment of 1 million dollars if he
chooses to retire
however if he's ousted from the group
the contract actually pays lapierre even
more
up to 1.5 million annually according to
the lawsuit neither the nra's first
nor second vice president signed the
contract as required by nra policy
governing procurement
and there's no evidence that the nra
board was even aware of the original
contract or its numerous
extensions and in addition to oliver
north several other people tried to blow
the whistle on lapierre but he
apparently retaliated against those
individuals
the suit also alleges that lapierre
hired other defendants in order to help
him further his self-dealing the new
york ag says that la pierre hired woody
phillips joshua powell and john fraser
despite their lack of skills or
experience for their respective roles
and responsibilities
at lapierre's discretion phillips
allegedly instituted a practice whereby
millions of dollars in entertainment and
travel expenses incurred by
nra executives were billed to the nra as
disbursements by the nra's largest
vendor
that practice evaded both the nra's own
accounting and board established expense
reimbursement process
and the irs requirements for proper
expense reimbursement
and according to the lawsuit lapierre
phillips and powell regularly used this
pass-through arrangement to
conceal private travel and other costs
that were largely personal in nature
and wasting substantial charitable
resources the lawsuit also alleges that
woody phillips who as treasurer
was responsible for managing the
financial operations of the nra
lied on financial disclosure forms and
set up numerous deals to enrich himself
and his girlfriend and according to the
lawsuit several of philip's staff became
whistleblowers in the summer of 2018
disclosing to the nra audit committee
long-standing failures by nra senior
executives including phillips and powell
to comply with nra financial policies
and procedures
and phillips allegedly set up a contract
for himself just before he retired that
was supposed to be for ongoing
consulting services to the incoming
treasurer but the incoming treasurer
told the new york ag
that he was not even aware of this
contract and that the contract was never
approved by the nra board of directors
the lawsuit also alleges that the former
nra chief of staff joshua powell's
salary
more than tripled a little more than two
years into his tenure
which started in 2016. his salary
started at 250
000 but rose to 800 thousand dollars by
the second anniversary with the group
and although la pierre described powell
as abusive to his employees
powell was promoted after his abuses
were discovered and powell was also
accused of directing charitable funds to
be used for the benefit of his family
including approving a 5 million
consulting contract with the firm
mckenna and associates
which in turn that consulting
organization ultimately hired powell's
wife and paid her 30 000
a month in consulting fees through the
nra and even before this lawsuit the nra
actually fired powell in january of 2020
for misappropriating funds
and the complaint alleges that nra
general counsel john frazier didn't even
meet the requirements
required for in-house attorneys for a
non-profit
and despite the lack of qualifications
he was simply hired to help la pierre
funnel money to himself and
others and that frazier is accused of
repeatedly certifying false or
misleading annual statements by the nra
now the lawsuit identifies 18 formal
causes of action against the defense in
other words
things that give rise to some violation
of law and the key claim against the nra
as a corporation is that it has carried
on conducted or transacted its business
in a persistently fraudulent or illegal
manner
or by abuse of its powers contrary to
public policy
and the lawsuit seeks the dissolution of
the nra as a non-profit in the state and
the second cause of action against the
corporations cites new york state law
that allows judicial dissolution of the
nonprofit where the directors or members
in control of the corporation have quote
looted or wasted the corporate assets
have perpetuated the corporation solely
for their personal benefit
or have otherwise acted in an illegal
oppressive or fraudulent manner
and if this relief is granted the state
seeks to distribute the nra's assets
towards causes consistent with its
mission statement
and lapierre phillips frazier and powell
are sued in their individual capacities
for injustly enriching themselves
because they obtained a benefit
that should have gone to the nra and the
new york ag asked that all of the men
repay the compensation and
reimbursements that they received at the
denture event of the company
the men are also being sued for their
breaches of their fiduciary and
professional duties to the nra and
are sought to be barred from operating
charities in the future and this leads
to one of the main counter-arguments
about the way that the new york ag has
handled this and actually seeking the
dissolution of the nra itself and
pointing to why it might be politically
motivated there have been a fair number
of people that have said that
if these allegations are true the top
officials at the nra should
obviously be prosecuted and forced to
disgorge the profit that they received
at the detriment
of the company but even if that's the
case the organization
should in fact remain even if we may
disagree with what that organization
does
unlike the trump foundation which
existed apparently
solely to benefit the members of the
foundation
and to be able to divert charitable
funds towards their own
aims the nra does a number of things
that fit with the mission of the
organization itself
even if some of those funds were
diverted by
the men at the top but the counter
counter argument is that
that's an incredibly low bar and that
these allegations do actually warrant
dissolving the company itself
but this is not the only lawsuit against
the nra
washington dc's attorney general is also
suing the nra foundation which is a
separate non-profit that's chartered in
the district
for allegedly diverting funds to the nra
to help pay for improper spending by
top nra executives and as a result the
dc lawsuit is demanding a constructive
trust be placed over the amount it says
was improperly diverted to the main
nra and the nra is also battling its
former advertising agency ackermann
mcqueen
the ad agency allegedly had an
arrangement with the nra to help them
cover up the excess spending
and the lawsuit against oliver north is
also ongoing so if new york dissolves
the nra
and removes its officers what happens
next well the nra would
cease to exist in the state of new york
but nothing would stop it from
chartering under the laws of a more
hospitable state
but if the court grants the state's
motion to seize and redistribute the
nra's assets the organization would
probably be crippled
even if they went to another state the
new york lawsuit seeks to remove the
core officers of the nra which would
likely mean that a new version of the
nra would need
a different leadership group but given
the popularity of the nra's mission in
the united states
it's likely that many other
organizations would probably step into
the vacuum left by the disappearance of
the nra would
would take over and many justify the
mission of the nra
and the second amendment as a way to
protect their family in their homes
but contrary to popular belief the
second amendment only allows you to
possess a firearm it doesn't absolve you
from the liability of using it and if
you did shoot an intruder in your own
home
you'd almost be certainly subject to a
massive lawsuit
a better way would be to stop a crime
before it happens
imagine if you had 24-hour video
surveillance and guards that could stop
a package thief or an intruder before
they got in
well with deep sentinel you can and i
can tell you from personal experience
that it's amazing i personally reached
out to them because i love it
i actually just moved houses and i knew
i wanted a new security system because
i used to live in a house with a
traditional security system with one of
those stupid keypads where
the alarm would go off if you didn't put
your code in in time and i actually got
fined hundreds of dollars
multiple times when the police were
called out unnecessarily
and i also tried one of those newer
systems with wi-fi cameras and all it
did was record the fact that somebody
stole my package
but deep sentinel is different deep
sentinel is the only security company
that
actually monitors your property in real
time and will actually
intervene before something happens once
the security system is triggered their
surveillance guards
actual human beings watch your property
in real time it's
genius and here's how it works first
when triggered
the outdoor camera starts strobing red
light showing that the video was
recorded and monitored
then a surveillance agent is notified
and makes a quick decision about whether
to intervene
and here's the best part the alarm
system has a loud two-way speaker giving
the agent the ability to find out why
someone is there or
stop them from doing something bad and
you can really see the advantage of
having a real person here
and finally if necessary the deep
sentinel agent can warn the person to
stop
and call law enforcement with a
description of the suspect
no one else can do that and because it's
real humans there are effectively no
false alarms with deep sentinel you get
a system that is proactive
not reactive with the traditional system
it takes several minutes before the
alarm is triggered and several more
minutes before the police arrive
assuming it's not a false alarm which it
probably is in the same time
frame someone can steal your package
break into your car or even break into
your home
at best the system will just give you a
record of what happened but all of that
is a thing of the past with deep
sentinel
and like any modern security system
everything is wi-fi and app enabled so
i can pull out my phone and check on my
front porch or backyard with one click
anywhere in the world
and for my phone i can turn on the
two-way radio and talk to a delivery
person or
guests and the system even automatically
tells me when packages have been
delivered
it's all wireless so installation
requires literally one screw
that's it when i moved i knew deep
sentinel was the only security system i
actually wanted so i immediately reached
out to them to sponsor this channel
and dave and tomaz didn't let me down
legal eagles will get
15 off when you go to deepsentinel.com
legaleagle
or use the promo code legaleagle at
checkout but this is a special deal that
will expire in 14 days and only if you
use the link below
before i installed deep sentinel several
hundred dollars worth of packages were
stolen from my front door
because you know dc but i haven't lost a
single package since installing deep
sentinel
if you're worried about security and
don't have the time to self-monitor a
video system and
who does give deep sentinel a try and
get 15
off using the link in the description or
go to deepsentinel.com
legaleagle plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel
but remember this deal expires in a few
days so do you agree with my analysis
should the nra be dissolved for
malfeasance or is it a political witch
hunt leave your objections in the
comments and check out this playlist
over here with all of my other real law
reviews where i talk about legal issues
in the news related to the trump
administration and kovid
it's all there so click on this playlist
and i'll see you
in court